first of all I'm sorry for what you're
going through like your your mother is
here
yes she's injured had to come in an
ambulance yes yes what's that like
horrible horrible there's no words to
explain this pain we're going to
explorable I mean I don't think we
deserve it
nobody deserves it nobody nobody should
go through it no family should go to you
physically how is she doing she's doing
way better I mean she's gonna cheat got
discharged today but we just want to be
safe and bring her in an ambulance but
we could have brought ourselves but the
hospital which I think very much still
so Hospital that helped us they brought
her in an ambulance and made sure
there's a nurse here with her so if
anything goes bad cuz we don't know how
she was gonna react we don't know I mean
that's the hospital in this and then the
cemetery that's different it's too hard
for people you feel that your stepfather
saved her life
yes he did take and there's proof
because the bullet went in here came out
here and went through the center console
and when he hit my mom you know it only
went in like an inch so it killed all
the velocity that had in the niches so
the bullet went through him first
yes yes just injured yes and then she
had another max police officer that
helped her 30 years police officer which
I think think come very much he said
your mom so lucky because the bullet hit
her here here and one guy got her right
here though so it's like she went like
this quickly like miracle you know what
I mean like she it sounds almost crazy
to describe that is lucky that's all
that's so lucky three bullets and only
one barely hear it because this one is
this one made but this one got her you
know what I mean so my my stepfather
safe for life he saved her life and here
you are here we are saying goodbye to
Ben goodbye
what is it that you want people to know
honestly I just wanted to first be safe
when they go out there we don't know
what's gonna happen any day I mean that
secrecy we're not safe nowhere so just
be safe when you guys go out there and
don't hate I mean don't don't spray it
hey Donna
there's too much hate going on at this
kid let's unite
we're all brothers I mean it don't
matter the curves you ski and don't
matter where you from no matter what
language you speak we're all human being
first so let's stop that hate so we
don't have to go through that your
message yes or no family Perry go to
work we were going to just one more
thing it's tomorrow's Friday it's almost
a week since it happened does it still
feel just feels like it was an hour ago
that's how
I feel I think I'm in a dream I mean I
still can't believe a nightmare yes yes
you can't wake up from that can't wake
up from
I'm glad your mother will recover
physically but emotionally because that
night she'll wake up like AHA what
happened or a pony
you know what I mean just that night or
when she was asleep so she's not she's
not good she's not really yeah she's
still suffering she's gonna need a lot
of help to get that bat out overhead
she's still in shock I think now having
this thing out I do another shot yeah so
yeah I appreciate your help anything
else that you want to say just be like I
said it be safe out there and please
please please share your love I mean
this is we're humans don't hate nobody
because of their color just help him out
if you can that's all you can do this
community has really come together as
that helped you in any way this come so
thankful community overpass for because
they have helped us in every which way
we needed food any do we needed they
provided us a lot of stuff so I think
this video pass which and the people
which are so great thing
to them and be safe thank you so much
for speaking with us I appreciate it and
so she will be she's been released but
just for precautionary measures they
have a nurse and an ambulance who
because you don't know emotionally
you